so if you have heartburn indigestion
gerd you're going to be very happy you
watch this video I mean we all know what
acid reflux and heartburn really is it's
too much acid right is there a
difference between acid reflux heartburn
and the overproduction of acid there's a
huge difference okay when you have
heartburn or acid reflux or gerd where
do you actually feel it do you feel it
in the stomach
usually not unless you have an ulcer
normally you feel it just above the
stomach in the esophagus or even in the
larynx as it can come up esophagus into
your throat and so what you're going to
soon learn is that heartburn gerd acid
reflux is actually the opposite problem
it's usually not an overproduction of
acid it's an under production of acid
and I'm going to prove it so let's go
through this I mean I would bet you
anything if you go to your doctor with
heartburn or acid reflux they're not
going to test the pH of your stomach
okay they're not going to check your
acids they're not going to look at that
because it's obvious that you have too
much acid but here's the problem when
you don't have enough acid the valve on
the top of the stomach doesn't
necessarily close tightly enough
and the acid can then regurgitate up
into the esophagus making you think that
you have too much acid when in fact you
have just acid in the wrong place it's a
well-known fact that people develop gerd
as they get older you don't normally
have this problem when you're younger
well
it's an exception to myself in my 20s I
had this because I had really bad
digestive issues but that was more of an
ulcer okay which actually also had some
acid reflux but normally speaking as you
age okay over 40 50 years old a lot more
people get acid reflux but it's also
true that as we age we lose our stomach
acid the acidity in our stomach becomes
less and less and less as we age so
that's kind of conflicting doesn't make
sense unless you really understand that
the normally the root cause of acid
reflux heartburn gerd is a lack of acid
even if you take a look at what is
normal a normal pH of your hydrochloric
acid in your stomach
should be between one and three now what
does that mean well it is the strongest
acid in the entire body in fact it's
between a hundred thousand to a million
times more acid than your blood your
acid is like battery acid and that is
normal because the function of that acid
is to help you break down protein to
turn that like beef steak that you eat
into like a soup and so that's what the
acid does it helps to unravel the
protein so then the enzymes that are
released from this strong acid can break
down easier so we can then go from a
protein to eventually amino acids amino
acids are like the building block of
proteins and so every time you eat this
long chain of amino acids protein your
body has to break them all the way down
into the small parts so it can then take
those small parts amino acids and then
build back up body tissues but let me
just kind of refocus on what we're
talking about we're talking about
gerd acid reflux acid indigestion
heartburn being caused by a weakened
acid or a stomach pH that's no longer
between one and three it's starting to
go higher as the numbers go higher
Things become less acidic so there are
two main conditions
of low stomach acids okay one is called
hypochlorhydria that just means low
acids so instead of being between one
and three it's like between three and
five then you have another condition
called a chlorhydria okay that means you
don't have any more acids but that's not
100 true because the definition of a
chlorhydria means a pH of greater than
five in men and a pH of greater than six
in women But realize that if you're five
or six that's still below seven which is
neutral so there's still some acid in
your stomach now if you just search this
just take a look at the symptoms of both
of these conditions okay and you're
going to find some very interesting
things both of those conditions produce
gerd acid reflux heartburn
bloating and all the other symptoms that
occur when you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid in your system
hydrochloric acid is there to help you
break down food especially protein help
you absorb minerals and vitamins
especially calcium iron magnesium
potassium and also vitamins too vitamin
A vitamin B vitamin C that hydrochloric
acid is there to help wipe out pathogens
and microbes that are trying to get
through to the stomach level into the
rest of the body so with the right pH
you can kill off the microbes so you
don't end up with an infection or a
pathogen and so if you don't have enough
acid you can become anemic because you
can't absorb iron as well as B12 you can
start getting a stomach infection
and even an infection in your small
intestine where there's
too many microbes and that's called sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
and because you're not breaking down
proteins your immune system is going to
react a little bit weird and you're
going to develop food allergies and even
autoimmune diseases without that acid
being really strong in your stomach
you're also at risk of developing cancer
in your stomach you're also at risk of
developing H pylori which is this
microbe
normally in your stomach doesn't create
any problem until the pH becomes
two alkaline
I mean even the strategy of this H
pylori is to increase ammonia which is
very alkaline so it can then survive and
so H pylori comes out of remission when
your pH isn't acid enough and also that
infection creates an alkaline stomach
and if you're not getting the minerals
and you're not getting the protein
you're also at risk for osteoporosis so
if you don't have enough acid in your
stomach you're going to feel it as
indigestion
bloating and gas especially now what is
mind-blowing to me is if you look up
these two medical conditions
treatment is not to add back the acid in
fact it's everything but that it's kind
of like um there is no specific
treatment you know I'll look at to see
if there's a genetic problem cancer and
treat that look to see if there's anemia
and treat that look to see if there's H
pylori and trait that but there is no
medical recommendation for increasing
the acid from both of these conditions
which are a loss of acid now if we take
a look at some of the major side effects
of antacids or ppis or basically
generally speaking acid suppressing
medication one of the main side effects
is a loss of stomach acid if you treat a
loss of stomach acid with something
that's going to cause a loss of stomach
acid what do you think is going to
happen
you're going to get worse but you're
going to feel better temporarily when
you eat
because you have all this acid that's
regurgitating into the esophagus if we
can keep that down you feel better but
you'll be having all these other issues
right and people that are on chronic
medications to suppress stomach acids
have a lot of issues and this could be a
completely avoided if they if someone
tested the pH in their stomach instead
of just assuming they had a problem with
the overproduction of this acid so I'm
going to show you a very simple
inexpensive way okay that doesn't
involve
an expensive test to determine if you
have low stomach acids okay I'm going to
show you how to do that but I just want
to explain a little bit more on this HCL
hydrochloric acid first how does someone
end up with lowered amount of
hydrochloric acid if someone has
hypothyroidism that can produce a loss
of stomach acid if someone doesn't eat
healthily they can develop H pylori
infection or let's say their immune
system is suppressed that can actually
pop up come out of remission and create
an alkaline environment and cause you to
lose your stomach acids just from that
and of course we already talked about
taking antacids or other medications
that can diminish your acid as well and
you can even develop low hydrochloric
acid from being on a low salt diet from
having a potassium deficiency from
having a zinc deficiency and even from
having an iodine deficiency there's
another reason why you might also have a
loss of hydrochloric acid
it's because you eat too frequently just
think about the digestive system our
bodies were not designed to eat every
hour and a half with three meals and
snacks in between as we do that over
time we're basically just depleting the
digestive juices we're weakening the
system to the point where we don't ever
have a chance for our digestive system
to rest in between eating it's kind of
like exercising constantly and never
giving your your body a chance to
recover and then all the insulin that
could create a diabetic situation and by
the way diabetics are four times more
likely to develop gerd than people who
are not diabetics so the number one
remedy to resolve this a problem is
betaine hydrochloride you can get it
over the counter it's not a medication
it's a natural remedy and the only time
you wouldn't want to take it is if you
had an ulcer and so this is how I'm
going to recommend that you take betaine
hydrochloride starting out okay because
you know if you had chronic heartburn
for a long period of time or acid reflux
you could develop an ulcer and so if you
took this betaine hydrochloride which is
kind of like a building block for acids
it can aggravate the ulcer so this is
how I would recommend taking it first of
all when you start eating right when you
get the first bite of food into your
stomach then take the betaine
hydrochloride because I don't want you
to take in an empty stomach and then
maybe for some reason you got distracted
and you didn't eat and so now you have
this acid that's going down your stomach
and you had an ulcer and then it gets
worse so you want to just have a bite to
eat and then take one okay and see how
you feel
and then with the next meal
you're going to add another betaine
hydrochloride okay so now we're up to
two but I would recommend taking it
slowly after you swallow the second bite
okay so we're going to gradually
increase the amount of betaine
hydrochloride but kind of mix them in
with your bites of food and so each meal
you're actually adding one more betaine
hydrochloride gradually until you get to
a point where you feel a warm feeling in
your stomach which means you've took too
much so then you just back off you've
taken one too many
so let's say for example you're up to
six okay and you feel this warm
feeling in your stomach well then your
dosage is five or when you feel the
resolution of the acid reflux okay so
wow I have no more indigestion or I have
no more acid reflux when I took three
well stick with three then you would
stay on that dosage for a period of time
maybe one to two to three months and
then you can stop taking it for a while
to see if this problem has been
corrected now of course in the meantime
you're hopefully eating healthily to
actually balance out these other factors
like iodine potassium sodium chloride
things like that as well as not eating
too frequently right you're on this
intermittent fasting program but
typically an average person's gonna
really need between one and six and when
you take it maybe you don't want to take
the whole thing in a handful you want to
take one at a time
as you eat through the meal but I think
this video is extremely important
because if you start taking
the wrong solution
for the wrong problem okay you just
never going to get better now there's
another reason why you may have Gerd
okay or acid reflux and it has to do
with a lack of a certain nutrient that
controls the valve of your stomach and
for that information I put it up right
here check it out